لا شيء اصعب من الام
الفقد وعندما تتجرع هذه الالام مره تلوى
مره تكون الامور اصعب
واشد ولكن ماذا عسانا ان
نقول حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل هذا هو خيارنا
قدرنا ويجب ان نرضى به مهما
كان فنحن املنا ان يرضى الله
عنا وان
يكتبنا مع
الصابرين هذا هو قدر خيار كل الناس في هذه
الارض كما تشاهدون افواج افواج الناس تودي
احبابها وفلذات اكبادها في كل يوم وفي كل
ساعه وفي كل
لحظه
ونحن
اسوه بكل الناس
نودع ماذا عسانا ان نقول يعني ربنا سبحانه
وتعالى يربط على قلوبنا وعلى قلوب كل
الناس وان يمدنا باسباب الصبر
والقوه وان يمدنا باسباب القوه حتى نستطيع
المواصله لحمزه ولكل
الشهداء
نقول باننا على
العهد يعني هذه طريق اخترناها
طواعيه اعطيناها
كثيرا وسقينا كما هو واضح بالدماء لان هذا
قدرنا
و نحن ماضون هذا هو التحدي
الكبير صحيح ان الانسان
يحزن
ويتالم ويتوجع
كثيرا فكما قلنا ليس اصعب من الام ووجع
الفقد فكيف اذا كان الفقد الولد البكر
فلذت
الكبد ليس بضعه مني حمزه كان
كلي
و روح
الروح
وكل شيء
ولكن وعندما نحزن ف الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم بكى
وحزن وهذه هي
دموع الحزن
والفراق الدموع التي تفرقنا عن
اعدائنا نحن مشبعين
بالانسانيه
وهم مشبع بالقتل والحقد
ولذلك نحن نبكي ونسكب الدموع هذا صحيح
ولكنها دموع
الانسانيه دموع الكرم
والشهامه وليست دموع
الجزع
والخوف
والاستكانة
نحن نعمل على الهواء
مباشره ولا شيء نخجل منه وولدي حمزه كان
معنا يعمل في طاقم قناه
الجزيره
و نحن بدانا قبل ان يولد
حمزه وامضي الان ما
يقرب اكثر من عقدين في هذه الرساله وفي
هذه
المهنه
الانسانيه بعد الاسره وبعد حمزه نحن
مستمرون بالتاكيد
مستمرون
لكن على كل العالم ان ينظر الى ما يحدث
هنا في قطاع غزه ما يحدث صعب ومؤلم وموجع
وكبير وما يحدث فيه ظلم كبير لشعب اعزل
شعب
مدني ما ي حدث فيه ظلم لنا
كصحفي قيل في يوم من
الايام بان حريه الراي
والتعبير وان عمل
الصحفيين والحصول على المعلومات والصور
حتى تصل الى مستحقيها من المشاهدين
والمتلقين قيل بان ذلك مكفول بالقانون
الدولي
وبالمواقف 100 وسبعه من
الصحفيين سقطوا وسفح دمائهم على هذه الارض
وكان احدا لم يسمع بهذه الاخبار وكان
احدا لم يرى ما يجري نطالب كل العالم بان
يضع حدا لعمليه لهذه المقتله التي تحصد
ارواح
الصحفيين واحدا بعد اخر اتمنى ان تكون
دماء ابن حمزه اخر الدماء من بين الصحفيين
واخر الدماء من بين الناس هنا في قطاع غزه
وان تقف هذه المذبحه وهذه المقتله ولكن
ايا كانت
الاثمان فنحن ماضون هذه رساله انسانيه
كفلها القانون الدولي وهذه وهذا
واجب نقوم به على اكمل وجه ابو حمزه يعني
في النهايه صبرك الله و اريد فقط ان اقبل
جبينك ليس من اجل الصور ولا من شيء انت
تستحق اكثر من ذلك عظمنا اجرك لا لازم
لازم نقبل حياك الله لازم نقبل جبينك
والله يرحم حمزه وباقي الشباب